hello and welcome back to game review my
name is Caleb Denby and today I'm going
to be walking you through a game between
Nikita
visu gov and Jordan Vaughn forest
I'll never pronounce the names of these
players correctly but that doesn't
matter I can pronounce their chests
correctly that's right efore east 6 d4
d5 we're in a French defense today white
plays Knight c3 which might be the best
move depends on who you ask
Knight f6 which might not be the best
move depends on who you ask and after E
5 AF D 7 we see the line Knights seer
I'm sorry Knights EE to not Knight Evie
- and this is not the main line these
days I think the main line is giving
blacks some problems but black chose to
avoid it with Knights EE to the main
line of course being f4 it's what I was
just minding there so we see 92 c5 c3
knight c6 putting some pressure on this
D pawn once again f4 is the main idea
but white delays this by playing Knight
f3
now after Bishop e7 a3 is White's choice
black goes ahead and castles now we see
Knight f4 putting some pressure on these
black pawns but Queen a5 move
highlighting the fact that by moving
this night you were no longer defending
your D pawn and this might cause you
some problems and here white played a
very very strange move that move is
Bishop d3 and so your French players out
there might be able to spot the problem
but if you want go ahead and pause the
video at home and try and find blacks
best move here okay alright if you're a
true French player at heart you probably
rubbed your hands together and laughed
at your opponent and said ha you hung
upon what a [ __ ]
what a [ __ ] he hung upon except you
probably didn't take it like this even
though you could have you took it with
your night because you're very very
strong your 2650 rate of player Knight
takes d4 Knight takes d4 C takes d4 and
everybody is laughing at Nikita the
chuga for hanging his pawn
of course this pin makes things very
very awkward but if you try to break
this pin with a move like b4 I'll simply
play Queen c7 and this is really
highlighting the mistake in your play if
you want to play C takes d4 I can give
this check for king king and rook and
after Bishop d2 there's just enough
pieces on the D file for me to get away
with Queen takes d4 without hanging a
queen to this tactic and this might have
been what Nikita missed in this case so
as always the true French players always
went upon in the center and in this case
that was the advantage Jordan needed to
try and make this game go his way we see
Queen h5 from him and now in this case
the best way to deal with this Queen
coming out here is to play the move f5
it doesn't look like the most natural
way to play but in this case it is the
best g6 is simply a little bit too
weakening here white can get away with a
draw after the move Knight takes and
Bishop takes and after the double piece
sacrifice there's no shelter left for
this King and you're going to see this
game and in a draw so you have to play
f5 if you want to try to win the game
you can also play the move h6
but this move is also a little bit too
too weakening although maybe this line
is also quite good for black f5 though
is this choice and I hear you at home
screaming it at your computer screens
why not Knight takes c6 well shut up and
I'll tell you
Knight takes e5 and there is a threat to
the bishop that you have to look out for
there's no time to take on f8 I will
take on d3 with check and if you try to
come capture my knight I will take on f2
reroute to e4 and then capture your
knight at my leisure
so the tactics work out with f5 white
goes ahead and castles but now after
Knight takes e5 black is taking a second
pawn in defending his six square C takes
d4 recaptures one of the ponds and do we
take this bishop no we do nots this
bishops bad thanks to our pawns on f5
and we want to pressure the white center
so nice
six instead we see Bishop III now and
after Bishop f6 the pressure on d4 is
mounting night e 2 makes an attempt to
defend this but after Queen b6 we once
again are attacking all of White's
weaknesses which makes things very very
difficult before Nikita see King h1
stepping off of this diagonal and
perhaps preparing to bring her up to g1
with some ideas Bishop d7 is the simple
reply by Jordan and after Abby for
defending one of the weaknesses Rick a
c8 note that he doesn't try to get
greedy and capture this pawn putting
himself into some unfortunate pens he
just simply develops his pieces gets his
pieces into the game he's always going
to be up this one pawn and he just needs
to activate his pieces stay stay or keep
up with white in terms of activity here
after rook ASC one we see nighty 7
offering a trade along the C file rook
c5 and black goes ahead and actually
captures the stroke on c5 and we see
this nice change in structure now which
after Quinn c6 it's a little bit unclear
who this change in structure favors of
course white now has some chances to
expand on the Queen side but the black
center is now completely uncontested and
I think in the end this turns out to be
a good thing for for black here 94 from
White Queen a fort is a safe Square
which attacks the weakness rook a1
defends the weakness and you might want
to be a little bit careful here if you
don't do anything I think the move moves
like Bishop C to start to threaten to
trap your queen you do still have the a6
square for the moment but you do start
you know you start have to you have to
start being careful excuse me in the
game we simply see Bishop EA giving this
Queen this square if it ever needs it
hitting this Queen as well so Queen h3
and now after Knight G 6 I hear you at
home again saying why can't I take this
pawn I want to take this pawn and the
answer is you you hung your rook so
maybe you weren't saying that at home
maybe it's just me instead we see Bishop
c2 Queen a6
rook b1 stepping out of this pin
but now our queen defends laterally we
still see Bishop f7 defending this pawn
just in time
f4 is White's choice trying to slow down
some play in the center for black this
Queen comes out to c4 and now after some
maneuvering this Queen is very very
active Black has kept his extra pawn and
the end is coming for white knight takes
f4 is a nice tactic to kind of seal the
deal after Bishop takes we simply take
this knight on d4 regaining our piece we
see Queen c3 Bishop c3 special comes out
to d6 rook c8 is blacks move and now
after b5 Bishop b2 a for Bishop a3 is
putting some pressure on to the C pawn
we now see a 5 from white black goes
ahead and captures this pawn there is no
way for white to really defend it
rook c1 is the move now painting the
bishop but of course there's b6 to
defend and now after g4 black kind of
made things a little bit difficult for
himself here he simply took this pawn on
g4 which allows a nice tactic from white
to try and get back into the game and
I'll let you at home try and find it
here it's a very unique situation where
you can make these pawns on the Queen
side work to his advantage
ok complete the move is rook takes e5
and after B takes c5 b6 and the point is
this pawn is very very close to queening
and it's going to be difficult to stop
with that in mind perhaps a better move
here for black would be to simply play a
move like d4 or if you try the same
thing you're going to run into
after take stakes you're gonna run into
the fact that these pawns are moving a
little bit faster up the board than in
the other line instead though I've takes
g4 rook c5 takes c6
stakes and now after rook c6 we see
Bishop c7 and this rook has to sacrifice
itself for this beep on and now despite
being up a full piece it turns out that
the black pawns are too much for white
to deal with we see bishop g6
captures this pawn Bishop f5 white tries
to keep this bishop on the board four
pawns would simply be too much in this
endgame for one bishop to deal with so
we see Bishop f3 and now c3 and this
pawn is going to cause cause white some
real problems
kingi one King out 7 Bishop d4 this pawn
comes to c2 and now after Bishop b2
black takes this opportunity to play d4
while this Bishop is tied down to the C
1 square king f2 now e5 Bishop d5 check
King f6 age 4 but it's just not enough
to stop all of these pawns for black
Bishop c1 and now e4 and after Bishop b2
the King comes closer we see Bishop g8
hitting this pawn simply h6 Bishop back
to c1 III for black and now if white
wanted to white could win a bishop with
bishop age 7 except he actually couldn't
do to g6 sunset Bishop b2 now Bishop b4
for black Bishop back to c1 g5 h 5g for
Bishop h7 check King e5 bishop back to
g8 now after E to white threw in the
towel after the move king F 2 and D 3 of
course white or black is simply queening
by force here you can give a check and
the king will come back to d6
you can give another check if you want
the King will come back to c7 and after
King you won the bishop and the King are
simply not enough to stop 3 passed pawns
coming down the board for example Bishop
c4 simply g2 and if you want to stop
this pawn
this pawn Queens if you want to stop
this pawn I'll Queen here and then Queen
here and like I said two pieces not
enough to stop three pawns and that is
how your Diwan forest managed to win
this game so another victory for you
French defense fans out there keep
taking those free pawns in the middle of
the board and pretending you're opening
doesn't lose by force of course white
didn't have to hang this pawn but you
know a definite victory for French
players all around the world there's not
many of them enjoy it while you can with
that in mind thank you so much for
joining me this week on frame review my
name is Caleb Denby and I'll see you in
the next episode